good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy hump day don't forget to help
someone you love especially
if that person that you love is wearing
new pet merch collection
from our summer 2021 drop that's right
today
we dropped some sickening merch on
shopmorningtoast.com
some of it is being featured here on me
some of it is being featured here on you
and some of it is even being featured on
theo that's right we've got collars
harnesses leashes dog toys dog bowls
we've got it all
shopmorningtoast.com it's very exciting
this is one of our most favorite chops
ever as we said yesterday and as we said
yesterday that very soon you would be
finding out what we were up to with our
little secret project so we did a little
shoot a little photo shoot
and we're just so excited about these
new threads
yeah so this summer collection we're
doing shorts i think for the first time
yeah we obviously have our crew necks
because we are just obsessed with crew
necks but we've also got t-shirts we've
got bucket hats we've got dad hats
everything you need for a steeny ass
[ __ ] summer and i love this
collection because it's two totally
different vibes like
the same items different vibes like the
nude to me is just like cool
kanye but also like camper kanye camper
vibe cool camper kanye
yes and then this one is just like fun
candy pleny
i'm wearing it today like i'm going to
the country club for a round of links
later
what size are you wearing i'm wearing
medium on both top and bottom
i'm wearing xl on both top and bottom
and i'm just feeling really great in my
own skin
yes and i would say that they fit true
to size i would say that yes
the the collars and harnesses also come
in sizes depending on your dog and the
dog bowls
are big like they're really substantial
theo's been loving it we have one
here for your p john or your pea jowl
make sure you uh hit up
shopmorningtoast.com
yeah they're nice and big so they'll be
getting lots of water lots of food lots
of breakfast
um happy hump day to you it's so nice
that it's hump day
i'm just so happy to be getting over the
hump of this week
it wasn't hard to get over the hump
because we slid into this hump day
with the real housewives of new jersey
last night i think we should talk about
our night how we did we went to an event
and like we definitely made the episode
we are definitely
in the background because we were there
for most of it like we were standing in
key places
held a pride event yes margaret held a
pride event in englewood and i think
we will be on the episode whenever it
airs just like in the background you
know a couple of french
we weren't seriously extra no it was
funny like we were with brian and we
were literally like talking ourselves
about like
how we were the least relevant people at
that party like we were full-blown
extras
but the way we were talking and acting
like we literally thought the cameras
were honest the whole time like we were
the most interesting people in the room
because we worked but it was cool to
just like see how the sauce gets made
yeah and it was a really fun event and
tina berner performed so for everyone
who knows
uh drag race it was jackie wasn't it
pretty sickening
it was amazing she she did this i don't
want to
ruin it she did an amazing monologue
yeah and
yeah it was all the things that you talk
about it was a comedy
it was a lipstick she's like all your
life yes and it was glam
yeah and the the house husbands were all
loving it jackie was a little star
struck who were you most like
star-struck to say
the whole cast was there except for one
person but that might be like part of
the story
and i was most starstruck to see frank
catania and did you say one word to him
nope because that's me yeah that's a
little you were four feet from no like
i'm just happy to be like in the
presence of someone it's like if i saw
kylie at an event we're not gonna become
best friends or anything like
i would just want to observe you know
you know and so it but it was really
like shocking to see frank and daniel
just like out and about and it's
probably like the
for the best that like you and i didn't
speak to him because you know ben's in
miami and i would have taken frank home
with me like
yeah but you were crushing on someone
else who
joe oh joe benigno is like has my heart
you know the love of my life but also i
did have some eyes for evan goldschander
like he really is so handsome
he is there it's just really exactly
what it seems like on tv
so it was really fun to be a part of it
yeah it was very cool to see like the
cameras and like
i just kept thinking like it was about
me you know and like it was hard for me
to realize like
it wasn't i just didn't want a camera on
me because i was trying to eat
the food was really the food was really
really it was great food and like
obviously you know me and jackie walked
before the ladies got there we thought
it was like safe like a good time to eat
because like they wouldn't be filming
so we walk over to the buffet and
literally we see a cameraman like
his one job was to film people going to
the buffet and getting food and jackie
and i literally did we're like pivot
nope that's not what we want to be known
for no we need to wait like another hour
to eat but it was worth it because the
food was really good
yes it was so it was a really fun night
and it was just like you know a night
out
so unexpected middle of the week but
here we are now it's wednesday now it's
wednesday and so nice to see of course
the ladies but also we saw taylor
strecker and ryan it was just like a
nice
you know reunion of the crew it was it
was nice to see some old friends
make some new ones and ben is out of
town this whole week and like you know
i'm
deathly afraid of being alone in my
apartment so like i have plans every
night
this week just because like i can't be
in my apartment alone like i will
like think there's a murderer and like
lock myself in the bathroom yeah so that
was you know
tuesday night check sorry if anyone just
saw me like
because touch my nose and look at it for
a minute it felt like i had a nosebleed
oh like well you know this change of
course i get crazy you know
there's like when there's like a draft
in your nose yeah 100 so i'm really
sorry it's alex rose like and the camera
was on me so
jackie was picking her up i had to clear
that up headlines it was worse than that
it was it was worse because i like
looked at my hand
so today's episode is great because it's
wednesday we have deer toasters
because we were so busy like being
extras last night i did not get a chance
to watch real housewives of new york me
neither um
but we'll just like catch up on the next
recap and dear toasters is still here
because it's wednesday even though yes
last week's dear toasters was like so
chaotic in a good way yeah
but i'm glad to be back on our hump day
schedule because it just didn't feel
right yeah and today we have a lot to
talk about because it's all pretty much
updates from stories from yesterday
and there's much to discuss so i think
we should jump right in sooner than
later but before we do i just want to
make sure that we hit all of our talking
points which is one merch is available
now at shopmorningtoads.com the summer
collection the pet merch
theo worked really hard on designing for
all the pups out there
and he wants to feel supported by you
guys and we worked really hard getting
those photos in the park in the hottest
like
sun i've ever [ __ ] felt in my life
when i got home
i thought i was gonna die like i've just
never like been that physically
laborious
in the sun in the middle of the park
like with people staring at us and it
was a lot for me to take on physically
but also emotionally and mentally yeah
so for that reason you should buy the
merch yeah and i'm just grateful that we
thought
that we didn't end up on influencers in
the wild oh my god i didn't even if you
had said that to me i would have said we
we
i wasn't part of like we were like it
wasn't in we weren't being influencery
we were like working and we were being
entrepreneurs like with our clothing
company like sorry we have a successful
brand maybe if you had a brand
that you were passionate about you would
know what it's like to run a brand but
you
don't okay shop morning toast.com head
over there check it out
quantities of things are limited this is
everything this is not an unlimited drop
come as you go like if you want
something and you know that you want it
i would say get it asap because i do
believe like
it's early in the morning when we're
recording this right now i do believe
that your shorts in the medium the exact
pair that you're wearing are already
sold out
wow but i would also say i could see
myself wearing a size small in these
shorts it would just fit a little
differently but cutely i could also see
myself wearing a size large
by the way i could also wear a size
large there's a really good drawstring
like it really
expands and it really tightens so like
the sizes are very flexible that's a
good
thing to note yeah they are flexible so
that's point number one point number two
as always the patreon is here for you
constantly and if you're not a patreon
member yet you are missing out so head
over to patreon.com to get premium
content and to support your girls
and you know what's so interesting about
the patreon is that
we live in an ever-changing world you
know things are constantly shifting
evolving that's what makes us you know
such a great country but the patreon is
always there for you like constantly
in this tumultuous world there is a
constant and that's the patreon.com
morning toast
it's true it's really really true so
head over there
and enjoy premium content really and
enjoy the stability that comes along
with it
yeah it could be a little chaotic
sometimes it wouldn't be chaotic if it
wasn't us
but the chaotic the chaos is what makes
it stable
that's gorgeous like absolutely the
chaos is
you can rely on chills chills
okay and now i think that's all for me
always you know it's a good time to
become a redhead we have two weeks till
the new episode drops so if like you
wanted to
pick up the new book it would be a good
time yeah and that's that on that
truly for me for me i really don't have
many left life updates either we were
just so busy yesterday like shooting our
you know being entrepreneurs shooting
our merch collection becoming you know
real housewives of new jersey that like
i really don't have that much to update
the party was just like so fun yeah
and it was open bar which was just like
an interesting factoid what did you
think it was gonna be
i don't know i just like never thought
like what our housewife parties
like the bar situation is it a cash bar
uh we've been to
you know a potomac event where karen
hugher was dismayed at the cash bar and
she said
that was a choice so i was just curious
like and it was open bar i thought
people would appreciate that little
like interesting factoid yes but i would
not expect anything less for martin
well margaret hosted the party yeah
she's like a true hostess i thought
i don't know why i just assumed the
party was going to be at her house and
when we were on the way
i was like can't wait to see margaret's
house and you were like it's not out of
her house i did i do really want to see
it though
yeah maybe you'll get yourself invited
maybe hopefully i was a good guest last
night i'll get myself invited back
maybe yeah okay so i think without
further ado
do i read a comment that someone didn't
like it so i'm going to skip over that
today
maybe no okay without further ado where
are you
okay he's right here because it's humble
that's it that's that on that
dude here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
oh oh god oh god oh god
oh no is everything okay claudia
she is my girlfriend sorry she has risen
that was
one of the symptoms of my rdh flare-ups
i just kind of like you know zone out
for a second but i'm i'm feeling okay
but my doctor did recommend i tell
everyone
about today's sponsor please do please
get that off your channel i would be
remiss
i would be devastated i would even be
heartbroken
if they didn't let you know that today's
episode is brought to you
sponsored by curology we used to think
our skin goals were unattainable what
are some of your skin goals like i just
want to have
like dewy well moisturized no blackhead
like not
skin is that so much to ask no and i
think the kids are calling it glazed
doughnuts
yeah that's what i want whether you're
trying to take control of acne or if
acne is no longer your top concern
fine lines dark spots occasional
breakouts or clogged pores
curology will customize a prescription
formula with three active ingredients
picked for you to tackle
your skincare needs to get your
treatment plan start by answering
questions online about your skin and
sending in a couple selfies to curology
it is a very specific quiz which makes
me feel very seen because literally
nothing is more different than
everyone's type of skin like we should
not all be using the same formula
so the pictures the questions about
texture bumps it's actually really
really helpful
after the quiz curology matches you with
a licensed dermatology provider
who gets to know your skin and if it's a
good fit you'll get a customized
prescription cream to address your acne
fine lines dark spots
and more the curology sets you up then
curology sets you up with a personalized
treatment plan and ships the custom
formula right to your door
honestly you do the whole process from
your couch it truly couldn't be easier
and if there's things that been
bothering you about your skin
and just drugstore products aren't
working for you it's probably time to
take it to the next level
level because curology is custom
formulated for you nobody has skin just
like you therefore nobody should
have the same formula as you and that's
what curology is here to do help with
texture complexion clarity pore size
anything
take control of acne dark spots
breakouts or whatever your unique
concerns may be
with a powerful skin care treatment made
just for you today
go to curology.com tmt for a free 30-day
trial just pay for shipping and handling
that's c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash
tmt to unlock your free 30-day trial
seekcurology.com for all the details
thank you for that claudia i'm glad to
see you're feeling better it was a
pleasure yeah i mean
it was touch and go there for a minute
okay first story update from yesterday
erica jane's lawyers
drop her after the hulu documentary the
housewife and the hustler not to be
confused with
the bakery i don't know if that's the
reason no but
it actually did come after i don't know
and by the way they did drop her
after this was that's just chronological
that's just facts so they actually
released a statement that was vague but
also like somewhat specific about why
they decided to part ways and i've been
watching like lawyers on tick tock kind
of break it down
yeah so this is what happened dinsmore
and seoul llp filed paperwork to
withdraw as erica jane's counsel in her
estranged husband tom gerardi's chapter
7 bankruptcy case
the law firm claimed it notified jane of
its decision no later than monday
coincidentally the same day the alarming
documentary
dropped while it is unclear what exactly
went wrong the lawyer said in their
court documents that quote
the relationship of trust and confidence
that is essential to a properly
functioning attorney-client relationship
has broken down and in the good faith
assessment of counsel
the relationship is irreparable
so yes what i learned on tick tock is
that like when this happens like the
lawyer has to provide some sort of
reason
for why they decided to drop but i guess
whatever the reason
was whatever the breach of trust is
telling the court would like
reach their attorney client privilege so
it's like very complicated but basically
like i guess erica did something behind
their backs is what they're saying
correct
i don't know or sometimes it might just
be as simple as the obvious which is
that they watch this documentary and
realize
what was ahead of them like i know that
maybe it's
it's not like that lawyers are watching
documentaries on abc news and like
making
like great decisions from it like i
think with dana and danielle style
no but like i think this documentary has
really changed the tone of this case
but see the thing with lawyers is like
you know
everyone gets a lawyer like o.j simpson
had a lawyer and he had a really good
one like
everyone even the worst people in the
world are entitled to a lawyer like
murderers
so whether or not a lawyer thinks that
they're going to win
they still take on the case they got to
get paid you know yeah so eric
unless erica can't pay them anymore
yeah but see no matter what like a
lawyer obviously is going to do the best
job to get you to win
but like low-key they don't really care
like they get paid no matter what
they're going to try and do their best
job
but they're not i feel like they're not
going to not take on a case if they
can't win unless you're like
tom girardi where like you know you have
a record and you don't want to like
lose yeah but they don't just take on
any case i do think that lawyers are
discerning but clearly they
they decided already to take on her case
so maybe something like personal
happened
that's what it sounds like she was
dishonest with them and
now they found out new information and
they
i don't know i don't know yeah it's very
vague but it's also
really crazy like this has just not been
a good week for erica yeah
and i feel like before this documentary
came out but we knew about like all the
lawsuits and stuff
her like activity on social media has
been like pretty
consistent like she's been acting like
kind of like nothing's wrong like she's
being kept out of it
but now i feel like things have
definitely changed the tone in which
we are regarding erica jane has been
changed because
i feel like now more than ever i feel
like she
she knew because of the documentary yes
the documentary has changed things
yes for me because i'm a [ __ ] you know
like and i'm easily swayed by
documentaries yeah but i think also
we were ready to regard this one with
the title and the cover photo and the
danielle style
opening like we were ready to be like oh
this is like
but it wasn't yeah i just don't think
that the documentary
swayed the opinions of her lawyers like
i think there was so much more going on
behind the scenes yeah yes
for sure but the timing is yes the
timing is very suspicious
and and now we also have this episode
coming out tonight which we will
definitely be recapping tomorrow also
if you're looking for the housewife and
the hustler recap we did a huge one
yesterday so if you didn't watch
yesterday's episode that's where it is
huge like you don't think they could
have watched the documentary and found
out that gerardi keys gave her 20
million dollars
that's in that's in court records if her
lawyers didn't know that they're not
very good lawyers okay
okay i'm just trying to think what they
might have found out that they didn't
know
everything abc news pulled they pulled
from public
paperwork like the lawyers or had that
information months ago
that's true that's true and
if they didn't think she could win and
they didn't want to take it on for that
reason they never would have taken her
on like yeah no i don't think it was
because they didn't think she should win
i think they found something out that
totally changes her case that she was
dishonest that we don't know yet
that me oh maybe yes i that's what i
think too
yeah but that's just conjecture and i
think we've made it extremely clear that
like we don't really understand
um lawyer no i'm an expert now like i
want your documentary i know everything
you watch what the documentary i'm
basically a lawyer right but the
documentary only
tells us so much like we don't know what
we don't know and that's what we're
trying to figure out
yeah but it all comes out in the wash
like once once the trials start
everything's delayed because of cobit
and also because
tom is claiming he has alzheimer's now
and is not fit to stand trial
but once everything starts rolling like
that's all public
information like we'll be able to find
out whatever we want yeah just these
things take so long and people's
attention spans are so short by the time
we ever
we even find out it's like two seasons
of beverly hills in the can and we've
all moved on
so true it's just it's really
frustrating you just want that instant
gratification where's my gavel instant
justice
instant justice so that's a crazy turn
of events we will keep you posted
tonight beverly hills is on i'm
really looking forward to this episode
now knowing what we know and now that
we're finally breaching this
topic like we know that at the end of
last week's episode she texted all the
girls
tom and i filed for divorce and that was
literally like 48 hours before
the whole thing unraveled yes of course
so i think it's so important that the
documentary came out this week because
now
we like are going into this with eyes
wide open it was
definitely intentional timing yeah no
but i think it was good timing because
you were saying yesterday you didn't
know if it was a little too soon because
the things hadn't happened yet we're
still waiting for the court the
documentary had no ending because this
courts haven't even started opening the
trial
but here's the thing the documentary's
ending is real housewives of beverly
hills
this was just a little prequel the one
is real housewives of beverly hills like
we're gonna
go on the journey for the ending this
was a prequel we needed this information
yeah but also real housewives of beverly
hills erica shows us what she wants to
show us
yeah the documentary was like the cold
hard truth out there
bravo is going to pry she got away with
that for a long time because it just
seemed like she had that kind of
yeah but what we're watching was filmed
in november and where everything starts
to unravel
yeah i know but eric we're still seeing
it through erica's pov so like she's
going to show us what she wants to show
us
i do think the reunion will be
transformative if she shows up
yeah she could go to jail i think she'll
show up and be like it's an ongoing
court case i can't talk about it
that's not enough that is not enough no
but like that's what everyone does and
everyone gets away with it
no but that's what everyone does when
it's like they're husbands like fake you
know like
beverly beach like this is the feds you
know this is the us attorney like
we need information erica it's not gonna
work for me i'm excited to watch tonight
me too okay next story another update
from yesterday we shared how michael
costello shared a story about chrissy
teigen bullying him and now leona lewis
says she was deeply hurt by michael
costello
after he accused chrissy teigen of
bullying leona lewis says you didn't see
her instagram stories
i'll share i was so busy yesterday like
it never happened leona lewis is calling
out michael costello one day after the
fashion designer accused chrissy teigen
of bullying him
this is so messy in a lengthy instagram
story post the bleeding love singer
claim that
that he made her feel quote very awkward
and uncomfortable
at a 2014 fitting for a charity fashion
show that she claimed she ended up not
being able to participate in
she explained that she was speaking out
about costello who claimed on monday
that he has unhealed trauma due to his
alleged experiences with tegan
because quote the pot calling the kettle
black in this situation doesn't sit
right with her
she said i usually don't speak on
subjects like this but honestly i feel
that i have to say something as i've
dealt with years of insecurity from it
i was asked to take part in a fashion
show to raise money for charity michael
costello was assigned as my designer
and as an excited young woman i flew all
the way to new york and was so honored
to work with him because i adored his
dress
dresses she said that she was made to
feel very awkward and uncomfortable at
her fitting because the dress was a
sample size
and she alleged that costello and his
clean clearly did not want to alter it
to fit me
this came as a total surprise because
weeks prior i was told that they would
make the dress work for me at the next
fitting the night before the show with
no explanation at all
michael refused to turn up he no longer
wanted to dress me and he abandoned his
commitments to me
and the show which made me well aware
that i wasn't the body type required
that's sad yeah um did michael respond
no no response yet um okay
one that's not cool of michael like if
let's say everything leona
lewis is saying it's true like knock
well i don't really um
like understand how it's relevant like
okay that's like a like that's not a
good interaction with michael costello
but it doesn't really have anything to
do with it it's not really even close to
on the level of what michael's saying
happen between him and christy tegan
like
telling him to kill himself and
blackballing him like that's just like a
like a that's a being a rude person i
don't know like
yeah seems like okay thanks for this
anecdote but like it's not really
relevant well she's just like saying you
know
yeah pot calling the kettle back and
then i'm sure in a few days we'll hear
of someone who
felt bullied by leo yeah no it's like a
cycle like everyone's would mean to
someone
yeah but also i i'm sure this totally
happened in the way that she experienced
it where she went one day and the dress
didn't fit and then
the next and last time they were they
all pulled out
but i could imagine a scenario in which
from michael costello's perspective like
that is just
one percent of what happened in his life
yeah
and maybe it had nothing to do with any
of that i really hope he responds to
this
me too because it feels like a story
where there
could be more to this story from his
perspective just because like
you never know what's actually going on
with someone else so maybe like in these
past nine weeks from your team and
stylist still requesting looks
the last email was may 17 2021.
leona i'm still a fan and i'm not coming
for you but let's talk about what you
were feeling about this dress i thought
you were happy
oh and i guess this picture he's showing
is on her instagram in 2015
she's wearing the red dress and she
captioned it i look so sassy in my aunt
michael costello dress
oh and then he posted another picture of
the two of them from his instagram in
2014.
i still love leona lewis i'm not sure
what happened between the middlemen or
what happened in translation i love you
leona
then a screenshot of an email a request
leona lewis
somebody emailed him hi michael i hope
you've been well i'm a styling assistant
we'll be dressing liana lewis for a
special performance of the american idol
finale she'll be performing at duet blah
blah here's the details they basically
wanted her
in a michael costello dress and he
captioned that screenshot if i made you
feel bad in 2014 but you still wore my
dresses and request them can we try and
figure out what got lost in translation
with the dress you wore you looked
beautiful in it
another one um i thought she looked
beautiful sorry i'm not doing interviews
about this and he's talking about the
original red dress in 2014 that there's
a picture of on her and
that was the dress she was supposed to
wear she that apparently wasn't
made to fit her and then they all pulled
out of the show and she didn't walk in
the fashion show at all
so when is she wearing the dress i don't
know she's wearing it and she's fully
glammed up
he said i thought she looked beautiful
sorry i'm not doing interviews about
this but i will talk about it here if
you think leona looks beautiful
let me know negative and positive
comments trust me i see them all even
the ones where people are now telling me
to kill myself oh god
when he shared the post this is leona
lewis she turned off the comments from
2015
so sassy in my aunt michael costello
dress so she said she
oh and he wrote here's a big sorry one
more statement he wrote no no this is so
interesting
i like how he's just like tackling
everything straight from his instagram
dear leona
lyanna leona leona yeah hello it's
michael i reached out to you directly in
an instagram dm after seeing your
instagram stories but i've yet to hear
from you
given that you've publicly shared your
experience with me on instagram about
coming to me privately first i have no
choice but to respond to you here
as i tried reaching out to you privately
without much luck i was really surprised
to hear about your traumatic experience
with me from the go
go red women's charity event 2014. i
flew to new york just to fit you and we
had a wonderful time at the fitting i
fangirled over you
told you how much i loved your songs
you're one of the most talented and
beautiful women i know we took photos
and i left options of dresses for you
with the charity
you told me you absolutely loved the
dresses so much so that even after the
event in 2014 you continue to wear and
post me on your own
i instagram in 2015. your team has
continuously reached out to me to pull
custom looks for you
which i was happy to create the most
recent request i received for me was may
2021 afterwards
you even invited me personally to fit
you in los angeles i remember having a
brief conversation complimenting you on
your dresses and your beautiful home
i don't take accusation accusations of
body shaming lightly as i built a career
celebrating diverse women of all shapes
and sizes but if i did unintentionally
hurt you and you continue to support me
i want to apologize to you directly this
caught me by surprise i'm completely
blindsided as you have always looked
fabulous in my gowns
and i thought you truly love them please
forgive me if your instagram stories
caught me by surprise you have never
indicated to me how you felt and you've
continuously warned me
tagged me and had your team reach out to
request more dresses as recent as last
month
i've lost tons of opportunities
sleepless nights and i'm not in a good
mental state of mind i wish you spoke to
me directly instead of on instagram
especially when i am at my most
vulnerable moment after years of trauma
and getting blacklisted with receipts
shown to me by all my friends and allies
i've been suicidal and often feel no
purpose to live i pray your intentions
are pure and that you're not acting
recklessly and attempt to smear me
and all the dresses i created for you to
save a friend if oh is monica rose her
stylist like i wonder what friend he's
talking about it's almost done or
chrissy
if i were you if you were in my position
i'm sure you would equally be a shock
someone who has continuously reached out
to ask for more dresses
someone who has supported you worn you
tagged you all of a sudden comes out and
says that you hurt them seven years ago
if i hear you in 2014 and
for for whatever reason you've continued
to wear me and support me please i want
to apologize to you
all of this is very shocking for me to
hear because you've continued to wear me
tagged me and asked for another dress
even last month
whenever you're ready i'm here let's
have a heart-to-heart conversation at
liana lewis
okay uh homeboy showed up with the
receipts so i truly
don't know what's going on here that's
shocking may 2021 but if she had like
such a negative experience that she's
been hanging on to for so many years
you would think like her stylist and her
team know not to reach out to michael
costello and she would never wear him
again and tag him on her instagram and
he was in her home
yeah literally last year for a fitting
what's the [ __ ] are leona lewis and
chrissy teigen friends i just googled
them
to see if they like and that went to
images but now it's all like these
articles
oh yeah you're not gonna find anything
but and i don't think monica is leona's
stylist because then she would have
never worn michael
right no this is like a really
interesting
i just i think the key to this is why
didn't she wind up walking in the show
yes i just would like to know that i
would like um michael to share
because she thinks that michael pulled
them both out
right whereas michael said he went for
the fitting left multiple dresses with
the charity and then went home
yeah so who's telling the truth you know
it could be like these are everyone's
versions of the truth and i think that
that's true but then there is the truth
and so let's get to it right so like
what caused her not to walk in the
fashion show
yeah especially if the dress what if it
was like the fashion show coordinator
was like the show's running long leona
you're out yeah right like
who do we blame for the cutting of leona
lewis we need to find out did she say
she just didn't walk in it because she
didn't have a dress no
she said she didn't walk in because the
night before michael pulled out like he
was her designated designer and then he
wasn't going to do the show anymore but
we have a picture of her in the dress
she felt as though it was because of her
size of her size
well like honestly and i imagine like
that's really how she felt and yeah i
just feel like
like now the conversation is like about
leona lewis and michael costello when
like we're talking about chrissy teigen
you know yeah 100
like no and like i'm saying even if
let's say leona's version is the version
of the truth and michael's just like
lying let's just say hypothetically like
that doesn't change like what we're all
talking about initially like chrissy
teigen
yeah you know yeah and there's they're
two totally different things
yeah now it's just kind of getting so
messy to the point where like i'm about
to stop caring and everyone that's what
happens everybody stops caring yeah like
i feel like people don't even care about
michael costello's response
yeah i think that they will because it's
like so different
from what she shared so bizarre speaking
of bizarre
the real housewives of orange county
casting shakeup
brought to you by stamps.com are you
still going to the post office
still paying full price or postage silly
silly girl
well thanks to stamps.com you don't have
to go anymore mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters ship
packages and
pay less a lot less with discounted
rates from usps ups and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
every year
because they bring the services of the
us postal service and ups right to your
computer
it's a must-have for any business simply
use your computer to print official us
postage
24 7 for any letter any package
any class mail with stamps.com you get
discounts up to 40
off post office rates and up to 66 off
ups shipping rates
not to mention stamps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive postage
meters they save you time and money it
is an absolute no-brainer stop wasting
time going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead
there is no risk and with our promo code
toast
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
are required just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in toast
that's stamps.com promo code toast
stamps.com
never go to the post office again words
to live by okay
oc real housewives casting news kelly
dodd
bronwyn windenberg and elizabeth lynn
vargas
are out at real housewives of orange
county and heather dubrow
is in in addition to three brand new
women who we've never met returning to
the franchise for the upcoming season is
former housewife heather dubrow who
exited in 2017 after five seasons
she will join current housewives shannon
bedour gina kirschenheiter and emily
simpson
and apparently three new housewives
here's the thing yeah
i have a lot of thoughts here's my thing
three new housewives
does not guarantee anything bronwyn was
a new housewife elizabeth vargas was a
new house their casting needs a whole
new
methodology because these women that
they're bringing in are just not cutting
it like
for a million reasons yeah so it's like
we're not even saying we need new i like
the idea that they're bringing heather
back because i think that they can go
and find people who have been on in the
past but i do think like when they do
that lydia like it's a horrible yeah no
heather is the exception though heather
is the bethany of the oc like i think
that
she will really elevate the show no
matter what but i just don't really
see like heather being on the same show
as gina kirschenheiter like i'm sorry
like they're just of
two different worlds like casita versus
27 million dollar like
house we are not on the same page like
like i just think like
they either needed to wipe clean
completely and like give me heather and
her friends like that's what i would
like
who lives in heather's gated community
like give me that i just think like
trying to mix old new
i think the production for oc has been
so bad for so long and the casting has
made literally no sense
and even though i think the shake-up is
necessary i don't know if this is
necessarily it because you're right like
three new housewives so they're just
going to be you know
fraunhofer and elizabeth vargas and
honestly i don't feel like elizabeth
vargas got a fair enough shot i don't
think so either she's got a coveted
season and she has a lot of money and
she's nuts
i think she was good and she gave us
like a lot she has
such a crazy backstory she was trying to
be open like
i think she deserved more of a chance i
am glad to see bronwyn go i just think
that she
crossed the line like there's just no
coming back for her from the thirstness
like
i will miss kelly dawn i will too
actually i know she was like so toxic
but
i don't know she i think she was such a
good housewife she always kept it
interesting even when she wasn't a part
actively a part of the drama
which she always was but even when she
was just you know laying low for a
season like she's just like
funny and interesting and her own woman
she also provides like a very good like
narration
comedy through her interviews um that i
think
is like necessary it's like a bethany
type like just being funny in your
interviews and like
giving a realistic kind of perspective
on what's going on
but a lot of the audience just did not
like her well and her lifestyle has
changed so much like
the apartment like you know like i'm
just she's not in the apartment
she was in the end she's married to rick
no i know and she's like in this little
house like
she's in the nice house she's in a small
house like she's
she's the show same street as shannon
shannon's house is little too and i was
just about to get to shannon too like
this is an aspirational show
and oc is falling into the real
housewives of new york category like
where everyone is living in tiny houses
it's a show about women who
used to be rich and now they're not and
they rely on the show for like all of
their
lifestyle groceries but if you're
cutting people out based on the size of
their homes
kelly wouldn't be on that lit like yeah
no but it would be gina
yeah shannon and kelly it would
literally be all them except for emily
no but emily
lives in a nice house but it they live
at in newport beach so it's like
and right and the show is about orange
county
newport beach and orange county yard not
the same they are power no but like no
wha they're the same but now they all
live in newport
yeah most of them and i think heather
dubois lives in newport too okay i'm
just saying like none of these houses
are cutting it this is a show about rich
women
like literally even they've they've all
elevated like from the apartment
yeah from shannon's rental but they live
in small beach houses like all next to
each other like this is
an aspirational show like 27 million
dollar home heather dubrow thank you so
much
emily's is not my favorite but it's a
nice big house and that's what i'm
looking for like
i need that bronwyn's like fake mansion
that was literally like
on it was like a mansion built on a
regular street with two homes so close
to each other you could see into the
neighbor's bathroom
that's what beach houses like beach it's
not good enough for me
okay but elizabeth had a big house not
good enough for me either that wasn't
big enough for you no
no it wasn't and she also was like weird
about her money like her porsche you
know
so it should just be heather on the show
because no one else has yes i think they
should build a show around heather like
heather actually runs in a fabulous
circle of people and these women are
just not fabulous anymore and sometimes
they make good tv like even gina who i
don't really like she made good tv
sometimes but like
again the casita it's just not gonna
work
yeah well she'll still be around i think
that heather dubrow's stipulation was
always that she would never come back to
the show while kelly dodd was on
interesting so i think that they might
have had to separate
kelly to make room for heather that
actually makes a lot of sense
yeah and i just think honestly if i'm
i hope i'm wrong but i think that like
you said like this the show is now all
on heather to save the show i think it's
too much pressure and also most people
wouldn't be able to live up to that i
don't think heather will be able to
yeah because she never gets her hands
dirty she was always like this
you know little bubbly character running
around just like sprinkling her fairy
dust on the show
she's not the show it's actually a
really good call
what also what is like this attachment
to shana madore i like chad madore like
i'm not i'm just saying like the trace
amigas were cut
shannon stayed literally the whole cast
is cut shannon stayed
she's not bringing it like she used to
and again the house
like i'm sorry i just
i think i don't understand the
attachment i think that my guess would
be that like
in you know focus groups and q scores
shannon tests really high i think that
people have this attack viewers have an
attachment to her
for what she went through i think it's
sort of like teresa giudice like
interesting she will always be a part of
it we will always
like feel and i was one of those shannon
people who like really
was empathetic towards her i don't feel
that way anymore but i think a lot of
women
do do okay that's a good reason that's a
good reason that would be my hypothesis
but it's just like she was a part of the
trace amigas and she was the only one
who didn't get cut
and then when she didn't get cut she
became part of like this new group of
women everyone gets cut
shannon's tease she is this like sort of
anchor in the show
and for a while i was like here for it
but now i just don't really understand
it anymore it's like just kind of dead
weight
yeah i think that oc should pivot
towards really being like
more of like those influencer mommies i
mean type of show
like medicine has a nice house um
tarek and heather ray young
yeah she's on another show i feel like
there's a more successful you know who's
actually in that community a little bit
too i feel like gretchen
like i just feel like there's a whole
community of like influencers in orange
county who are like
young moms who they could make like real
houses of
of see like its own thing again because
i was just like just
always trying to compete with the big
leagues and it's just not that there's
just like random women being pulled in
different directions i agree there's no
like real true social circle
that's why like even though heather
dubrow is not the most interesting like
pot stirring whatever
if she has like a fabulous group of
women friends in her community who would
be like down that would be a great show
and that
could compete with the big leagues yeah
but i don't think they want to be on
and i don't think even i don't know that
she has that yeah you know
like where is her home who are her
neighbors i don't know who lives near
heather dupro
we have to go location scouting we have
to look at the ariel knock on some doors
yeah that's what that honestly oc
casting should be doing
i'm sure that they do like knock on
doors truly yeah
they should whatever let's be positive
it's something like
last season was so bad partially because
of covid but just partially because of
this ragtag group of women
i do feel i do agree with some of the
cuts i do think elizabeth vargas i could
have been given a second chance like
building her big house and her big
charity you know like that whole thing
like
there could have been something there
but whatever i agree let's see
we'll see yeah i love terry so excited
to see terry again
yeah but you could always see terry
unboxed no
i do not like botched oh i think that's
just so good oh my god it makes me so
nauseous like i literally like my like i
can't watch it like you know
yeah yeah but you just have to close
your eyes like the pulling of the skin
oh my god it like really grosses me out
but it's a really good show
okay next story another update from
yesterday we shared that alex cooper is
taking her show to spotify for around 20
million dollars
correction flash update it's 60 million
dollars
it's 20 we weren't wrong it's 20 million
dollars per year no but i mean
variety wasn't wrong variety was
reporting 20 million and then it changed
oh it did yeah because like the
announcement fully came out no and i
yeah i think they
they got more clarity on the situation
that's what it's worth like i actually
when i first heard 20 million i'm like
that's kind of little
oh really yeah and now i feel even more
steadfast in my opinion from the caller
daddy drama that like
they specifically sophia were not even
close to being greedy for asking for
a million dollar salary like the show
was worth so much more right
60 times more literally so
it's just so crazy like it's like it's
just been in the news so much for like
the last year i'm like this is
definitely like the end of the
the chapter like now caller daddy's like
found a permanent home yeah at least for
the next three years
and it's just so crazy yeah it's really
crazy the first episode came out i
haven't had a chance to
to take a listen but is there a guest i
don't know i didn't even i didn't look
at anything
i didn't i couldn't wait i wasn't up
until midnight
60 me neither i went to bed so early i
was literally exhausted from being an
extra
no it's hard work no putting the show on
our backs and like you want to like
stand
straight and like smile the whole time
make sure you have nothing in your teeth
and like being that self-aware for so
many hours even though the camera's
literally not even looking at you it's
exhausting
yeah so i went to bed really early and
some of us were failed and having
nothing in our teeth
yeah jackie because one time gold
schneider came to our table i was like
had just taken a bite of food and i felt
stuff in my teeth so i was like keeping
my mouth shut the whole time
so that'll be fun if that comes fair and
it was spanakopita which is spinach
which is like the most
like classic no i felt it and so at
least i knew
and they were like yeah oh my god like
big smile
okay fifth and final story a little
almost casting news that i find so
interesting
as we know before wait really quickly
somebody pointed something out to me
yesterday and i was laughing
hysterically when we were talking about
gaston
and we were talking about the prequel
and how you know hugh jackman might be
good for the sequel
gaston dies in beauty and the beast
there is no sequel
just wanted to make issue a correction i
feel like they could have
they could make it that like gaston had
like a life-threatening
injury he bounces back i guess we never
got like confirmation but he falls off
the roof in the
you know the battle with the beast yeah
maybe he fell on his feet
yes you never know i think they can make
it work that's not
neither here nor oh he fell yeah he was
like he fell on his back he literally he
would have to have complete spinal
reconstruction surgery
from his shattered spine
people have come back from worse it
could be done it could be done but you
know it is like the french revolution i
don't know if they have the technology
for that yet like the medicine and the
science but they do have magic because
it was beauty and the beast so maybe
agatha comes through and says i'll fix
your spine
if you become a better man if you become
a better man or they put oh
then they put the beast hex on gas stone
yeah and he loses his good look that's a
really good premise
you're welcome free idea just like jake
and logan fighting each other
okay a little almost casting news as we
know anne hathaway was not the first
pick for devil wears products
she was ninth but do you want to know
who the first pick was who they offered
the role
three times they wanted her to play so
badly rachel mcadams yes
i did see this news story oh you i was
like is this old news but no you saw it
rachel mcadams was the first choice for
the role of andy direction she would
have been great
she would have been amazing that chaotic
and morning glory energy oh my god yeah
no she would have been great
yeah she wanted to die like when she
didn't take it i don't know director
david frankel said that prior to casting
hathaway the studio initially wanted to
cast a well-known actress to play the
part she turned it down
three times the studio was very
determined to have rachel starr in that
movie and she was very determined not to
do it that's so interesting
i wonder why i i mean i can't imagine
i'm sure now she's like everything
happens for a reason but
she's fine and the success of the movie
was so big but i'm sure she knew it
would be a successful movie like meryl
streep was in it yeah that's
fashion it's vogue like so why didn't
she want that role
why didn't she want to be that girl
maybe she had another project that she
was like passionate about
maybe and maybe if you had a business
that you were passionate about you
wouldn't know what it's like to turn
down a movie but you don't
um i could definitely see rachel mcadams
like being andy anderson or whatever her
name was
andy anderson has had to lose a guy in
10 days no and also some of the other
actresses that they wanted before ann
kirsten dunst no i couldn't see it
scarlett johansson couldn't see it now
she's too beaut like conventionally
beautiful whereas like andy in the
beginning has to like have frizzy hair
and like
try literally princess diaries yeah oh
my god
literally natalie portman no kate hudson
would have been really good i think no
no andy anderson but she's just like a
little too
cliche commercial yes well they
literally said more commercial actresses
so
yeah so i mean obviously everything
happens for a reason
but then crazy if she did take it
because
that would mean that she's in mean girls
the notebook and the devil wears prada
literally like three movies that are so
ingrained in our culture and like in the
zeitgeist of like our generation
that would just be crazy she would be
like the biggest actress of all time
yeah and plus the morning glory like i
know we just
we regard it as an important movie but
other stuff no i know every
everybody does um but you know what i
like on watch strap inside when i'm
wedding crashers yes on watch weapons
live andy always does like
you know um ask questions about things
famous actresses like went out for
didn't get
turned down do they regret it and you
know really even like huge
like things people like someone turned
on the titanic or whatever people
like successful actors they really don't
regret most of those decisions like they
just like
it's just like a choice that you make in
life like you don't think about little
things like i wish i took that job you
know
yeah so and you know if you're on watch
what happens live as a guest like things
you're successful things worked out for
you so i guess yeah you wouldn't lament
what you didn't
do but maybe just say that publicly
rachel mcadams like
was too good for the devil wears prada
but she wasn't too good for eurovision
the movie i just don't see how that
kind of parallel like maybe it came down
to the paycheck
for sure but like rachel mcadams is like
really did a good job of being
like a teen star to like a full black
spotlight you know she went from mean
girls to spot like get you a girl who
could do both but yes she was
a star for the teens but she wasn't 18.
no she's only 27.
she when she was a child star who
transitioned no but like she was going
to the teen choice awards like for me
girls with gretchen weiners yeah
same with amanda seyfried a lot of those
girls transitioned well from me girls
some of them
some of them didn't but then went to
hallmark and what better place to be
um let's dive into your toasters because
we have no tv recap segment today
and the deer toasters is brought to you
by better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
where you can start communicating in
under 48 hours better help is not a
crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available to you in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide where you can log into your
account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting waiting room again
as you do with traditional therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free
to change counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com toast that's
betterhelp.com
toast and join the over a million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
so today's podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and morning toast listeners
can get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com toast twitter help is
the perfect sponsor for dear toasters
because sometimes we can't help you but
that's true but better help ken
all right first up again your toasters
at gmail.com is our email if you ever
want to write in about a quandary you
are having or update us if we've ever
read something about your story on air
hi jackie and claudia oh sorry hi
claudia and jackie
i enjoy dear toasters so much i recently
got engaged last month and one of my
childhood friends immediately
congratulated me by saying
ah i've never been in a wedding and i
was not planning on making her
bridesmaid at all
on social media she saw that i was out
to dinner with a friend and my friend
captioned it wedding planning
she then texted and asked what the bats
when the bachelorette and wedding was
i haven't even started every anything
i'm already overwhelmed with her
involvement
we've stayed in contact since we were 10
years old but i wouldn't consider her to
be a best friend of mine as of right now
my fiance and sister have advised that i
need to make her a bridesmaid but i do
not want to
how do i tell her that i'm not asking
her do i just ignore when the time comes
i'm sort of a people pleaser so i know
i'll feel guilty but i also don't want
to be a doormat and have
her forced into my wedding party please
help i agree like this is the time to be
selfish like you don't just give away
bridesmaids cards
their coveted position yeah just because
she's being a bull von
i'm just in a place in reading the story
i'm just like you need to rip off the
band-aid send a text message be like
thank you so much for the love and
support i'm keeping my bridal party
small so unfortunately you
won't be up like find a way to say more
of the ignorance
no don't ignore because this girl's not
going away and like it will hurt more
it will sting more if it's last minute
and like she sees that there's a
bachelorette party like without her just
be like
i'm sorry if you expected otherwise i
am keeping my bridal party small and
blah blah i can't wait to celebrate with
you at the wedding yeah
just don't make her want to bring her up
i'm just really in a
state of mind in your life i'm in a
place in my life of just like
speak your truth and move the [ __ ] off
well definitely don't just give up don't
listen
will literally be on your mind if you
ignore it until like the conversation
happens like
just send the text and move on yeah
definitely do not give away the position
just because like you feel pressured i
think your fiance and your sister are
giving you like truly terrible advice
definitely do not make this girl one and
how you want to handle it is up to you
like i could definitely understand
someone like just wanting to ignore it
and hoping it
goes away but the more mature and like
nice thing to do for your friend of 20
years
is to send attack but i just want to say
i think she's also being manipulative
because
my best friend on earth god engaged i
wouldn't say
can't wait to be a part of the bridal
party i've never assumed i wouldn't say
i can't wait to be in your wedding like
it's not about
me and it's not a giveaway i don't even
have
it's literally my sister gets me i know
i'm being a bridesmaid i'm still not
making it about me being a bridesmaid
i think this girl's manipulative and i
think you should put an end to it
because no one people don't say that no
this is actually really toxic of her
you're 100
right she's she knows she's on the fence
and she's trying to not give you a
choice but let her know you have choices
and you've made it yes
it's a choice and you've made it send
the text hashtag
that one almost slipped right by us i
didn't even realize that the
manipulation if i were her
i would never just be like can't wait to
be in your wedding even if it's my
childhood best friend
no it's like a really toxic thing to do
it's not even that it's just like
that's not how people speak because news
alert it's not about you
it's about the people getting married we
get so many deer toasters about like
weddings and engagements and honestly i
feel like there's a special [ __ ]
place in hell
for anyone who makes someone else's
wedding engagement bachelorette party
bridal shower about them like i think
those are the
literally the worst people ever
especially when it's a grown-ass female
like woman no and if you're getting
married like it usually is because you
have to be
a grown-ass female right and then it's
like mother-in-law's like that's just so
toxic and it's so
there's a special place in hell dead
serious for like women who do that yeah
and i think that those
women in these moments serve to show you
like who is going to
like be in your life yes and who is
manipulative and makes everything about
them
because as life goes on life gets harder
and you don't have time for people like
this and you're not meant to be friends
with everyone forever so people like
no doubt will just fall off of your life
off of your content plate
and the ones that stick around are the
people who like know their place no like
all
of the rigor moro of weddings are there
to let you know like who you need to
china from your life
like who cannot handle and i think that
this friend of
20 plus years needs to be china no she
can sit in the back row
yeah of the wedding um all right we also
have another wedding one great
your majesties wow no one's ever called
us that before i don't even know where
to begin
i was engaged and supposed to be married
last year very long story short he ended
up being a drug addict that i did that
didn't want to change
and i was right for leaving however i
planned a bomb ass honeymoon to europe
with a lovely travel agent that i
obviously didn't get to go on
i feel bad because this ain't the saint
of a travel agent i'm sure worked on
commission
and didn't get it when i had to cancel i
also feel bad because this is my dream
trip that i planned essentially by
myself and i really want to go on it
is that weird i'm taking a massive test
for my professional career next month
and i could reward myself with this trip
but i'd be going by myself with it being
so last minute friends and family didn't
have time to come up with the money
i truly feel rdh if i didn't take this
opportunity but i've never traveled
alone and there's the shadow of
of my would have been honeymoon hanging
over everything too help a travel hungry
toaster
go literally go like go go go if you are
someone who's even considering traveling
by yourself i think you are
able to travel by yourself i think that
you'll be able to handle
the solitude of it also there's so much
to see there's so many
new people to meet so i think that you
should definitely go i think this could
be so therapeutic
i recently traveled by myself to a
wellness physical treat
and it was the greatest thing i ever did
for myself
in my life so i mean for me it was it
was a retreat that i needed but for
others it's a european vacation
and i think like you're going to be like
lizzie mcguire like you're going to
live it up you're going to wind up in a
sneaky brown roser with a hidden agenda
for sure wind up on stage at the
coliseum
and i'm so excited for that for you go
go go definitely go but also evaluate
the type of person you are like
i know if somebody literally offered me
an all-expense paid trip to paris by
myself like i would turn it down
i'm not that type of person so i just
like i just want you to make i really
think you should go but also make sure
like you're the type of person who's
content
traveling alone like i am not no but
here's the thing like she already
we already know that she is because you
would never even think or consider to go
on the street
if you're having something like you're
having this urge and like you're just
looking for the encouragement
encouragement completed and be one of
those people like be one of those freaks
who like talks people on the plane like
talk to people at the hotel like go to
the hotel bar
maybe we'll meet a fellow soul traveler
who's you know fiance didn't work out
like
there's the endless possibilities like
and we're living in a post-pandemic
world
norma kamali would say go and not only
go take a jeep to the edge of a cliff in
italy or whatever it is you're going and
just go
jump no totally and you know it could be
eprey love i've never seen the movie i
read the book but it seems like that's
something about that it's something
about that
or also a movie that about a solo travel
traveler holiday in the wild starring
kirsten dunst
hashtag it was supposed to be her
anniversary trip with her husband
oh yeah she still wanted to go and she
ended up not leaving
watch that movie yeah watch that movie
on the plane it's on netflix
or watch watch it to get inspired to
make the decision hashtag
wwnkd what would norma kamali do
she would go and if you want to be like
norma you should go too
all right third and final dear toasters
how you darn okay
buckle up this is some craziness and i
need help handling this in the best way
possible
let me be in a picture my fiance and i
recently got engaged in december and we
have planned our wedding
for april 9th 2022. we are thrilled
my brother who is the sweetest will be a
groomsman in the wedding he just started
dating a girl first big time girlfriend
back in august
she is awful but he's in love i come to
recently find out her birthday falls on
our wedding day my first instinct is
whatever no big deal she gets to party
for free on her birthday lucky her
well i'm wrong she just sent me a
facebook message also who uses facebook
messenger anymore
at one in the morning say how much is it
to switch your wedding
day from my birthday i'm willing to pay
say a hundred grand what say all of our
vendors booked
down payments made does she not
understand how weddings work also she
gets a birthday every year the audacity
how do i tell her to kindly [ __ ] off i
love my brother and at this point he
knows i do not like this girl
although i've been incredibly cordial
thus far i'm worried it will cause a
rift in my brother and i's relationship
he says he understands both sides for a
little more context she has minimal
friends and family so he's kind of all
he's kind of all she has but still am i
crazy how do i move forward in peace
signed a bothered by to me first of all
you are not crazy that is literally
that's the
most thing literally you have to have
the biggest [ __ ] balls to send a
message like that first of all nobody
cares about your [ __ ]
birthday we're all grown-ups so like if
we're all like at the age of being
married and we're all crying about our
birthdays like i can't stand people like
that first of all you're so immature if
you do that first of all
second of all you have no social
awareness you have no self-awareness you
have the biggest
clitzba on planet earth to send a
message like that to ask someone i'm
willing to pay
i hope you ignore this message and just
ignore this girl in general do not give
her the time of day
you need to sit down or tally up how
much it would cost to move everything
triple it for you know the time that you
would have to spend
on working on this and give her a number
no i don't even think this message is so
ludicrous it doesn't even deserve a
response
whatever the cost of the wedding is
triple it and say that's how much you
want to pay me that much i'll [ __ ]
move my wedding make a couple
g's off of it no i think it's such like
a rude
message to even send it like to respond
to it would be
she needs to be like she's been put in
her place like this is a question that's
not even worth answering
how much would it cost i'll pay like are
you kidding me
but like she's really gonna put her in
her place it's her brother's girlfriend
like and also it sounds like right as of
right now she's just gonna like ignore
the situation i think you should give
her a number see if she'll pay
this is exactly what we were talking
about two years two years ago people who
make their weddings about you
and you might have been nice if she
hadn't been such a little [ __ ] like you
might have been nice and that got in a
cupcake and like had people at the
wedding like saying happy birthday like
that would have been cute and nice
a little something for the girl but no
now
china china i think you could be
enterprising about this and maybe make a
couple hundred thousand dollars
okay i'm seeing is she a rockefeller
like she's paying for people's weddings
i'm seeing a business opportunity yeah
like make an excel spreadsheet with the
cost of everything and then also triple
it because you know
the time stress that it will cost you to
move everything also like you are a
business person an investor so you want
to make a little money
and then give her a number or just
respond like a million dollars
yeah that's what i'm saying no i still
think it's so rude it shouldn't be
responded to
someone like how much would someone have
to pay you to move your wedding
think about it i would i would do it all
again for the
million dollars a million dollar
whatever it is figure out that number in
your head
give her a figure yeah but still like
seriously and your brother sounds like a
piece of work i understand both sides
like
you know and you know what there's
always something very weird about
someone who has like very few friends
and family around them like
what did you do like you are toxic
there's always a red flag like
when people have like new girlfriends or
friends that they bring around and that
person has like no friends or family
like
that's [ __ ] weird and like shady like
who did you murder yeah no just
everybody hates you and soon we will too
that's no you don't know why yeah yeah
100
um all right so those were deer toasters
very uh wedding themed
deer toasters guys are stressing us out
man no i know that last one that kind of
got to me like really made me angry
i hope you make some good money off of
this yeah that's my hope for you
and i hope that you spend it at
shopmorningtoast.com our new merch
collection
summer 2021 has finally dropped shorts
crew necks t-shirts bucket hats dad hats
and a whole pet collection
leashes dog collars dog toys dog
harnesses
dog bowls that's a pea job and pee jow
on it head over to shopmorningtoast.com
check it out i'm wearing xl jackie's
wearing mediums theo's wearing you know
cuteness ever i think he's actually
wearing small um he's so small
he's so small but they're also
adjustable so don't worry about that and
that's our show
that's our show and we shall see you
tomorrow thank you so much for listening
to the morning test the monday morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitch or public radio i
have radio catwalks all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find out
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
guys have an amazing hump day do not
forget to hump someone you
love have a great day you guys we'll see
you tomorrow goodbye